the secretary of state is mike pompeo
and uh mike pompeo yesterday said
during a brief press availability that
once every
legal vote is counted there will be a
smooth transition into a
second trump administration so he is
continuing to appear
to reject the fact that democratic
challenger joe biden
is now the president-elect of the united
states and has defeated donald trump
this is now going very high this is not
republican senators being quiet
this is the secretary of state a top
administration official
refusing to accept the results and of
course why wouldn't he the top
administration official donald trump
continues to say he won pennsylvania and
nevada and wisconsin and georgia and
other states
let's take a look at the video of mike
pompeo is the state department currently
preparing to engage with the biden
transition team and if not
at what point does a delay hamper a
smooth transition or pose a risk to
national security
there will be a smooth transition to a
second trump administration
all right we're ready the world is
watching what's taking place here we're
going to count all the votes
when the process is complete there'll be
electors selected there's a process the
constitution lays it out pretty clearly
the world should have every confidence
that the transition necessary to make
sure that the state department is
functional today
successful today and successful with the
president who's
in office on january 20th a minute
afternoon
will also be successful so this is
actually starting to sound
mildly seditious which is about right
for this administration
this is actually terrifying not because
it might actually
prevent joe biden from becoming
president but because it shows the level
of disconnect from reality
that more than just donald trump have or
alternatively the other explanation for
why mike pompeo is doing this
would be pompeo knows that trump lost
but he's been bullied into repeating
this nonsense which is arguably just as
bad
now consider that mike pompeo has a lot
of official travel coming up in the next
few weeks mike pompeo
is supposed to go to france turkey
georgia israel qatar
the uae saudi arabia the leaders of some
of those countries that will be visited
by mike pompeo in the coming weeks have
already congratulated joe biden
um israel is an example francis is an
example the others i'm less sure about
what does pompeo say to them when he
gets there
uh we're not leaving don't worry we're
getting another term you're going
to be working with a second trump
administration and not a biden
administration
even though you've already congratulated
joe biden and kamala harris
how is that going to work and from mike
pompeo's answer yesterday
this is still shaping up to be a very
long couple of months
and also a very humiliating couple of
months for the trump administration and
we've talked for years now about
the normalization of really crazy things
under the trump administration
comments like these from mike pompeo
these are
unprecedented by state officials in
situations like this
it is not common that in the united
states
after an election is done after the
votes are in uh
showing that there is an irreversible
victory
by one candidate after that individual
has started an office of the
president-elect has started a transition
for a secretary of state to still be
denying that that is what has taken
place this is unprecedented
and we should not allow it to be
normalized first they refused to assist
in transition planning
now they're suggesting there's no need
for transition planning because trump is
going to get himself a second term
now i want to ask trumpists a question
and i worry i know the answer where is
the line
when will the disdain for democracy
and the continued authoritarianism be
too much even for trumpists
i don't know that i need to ask because
recent polling shows that most
republicans now believe
donald trump that the election was
stolen
by joe biden it's actually that bad and
why would we think there is a line
they've spent the last four years
defending
everything donald trump has said and
done no matter how outrageous
no matter how dystopian or authoritarian
including
suggesting as donald trump did that he
could murder
someone on fifth avenue um without any
political repercussions why would we
believe there is any line
trump could cross there isn't and this
is actually donald trump's best chance
at staying in office
the only thing that if you force me to
come up with
that i find the slightest bit
interesting about this entire disaster
is the idea that if donald trump really
is going to try to just stay
his removal from the oval office on
january 20th
is going to be absolutely riveting and
uh rewarding to see but it will greatly
damage
and embarrass the country if it were
come to that if it were to come to that
so as entertaining as it would be
as much as i would relish seeing donald
trump being removed
uh i actually hope it doesn't happen
because it would be really bad for the
country the american people have spoken
it's time to go guys i get it it's a
thin margin couple
hundred thousand votes in four states uh
70 000 votes in two states but
trump only won in 2016 because of 77
000 votes in three states it was close
then as well
if it were popular vote hillary would
have easily won in 2016
by popular vote joe biden won even more
easily in 2020
but it's time to go you're embarrassing
yourselves this was a fair and rightful
process
where people chose their leaders they
are not just trampling on the process
they're ridiculing the process and in
doing so ridiculing the united states of
america
which deserves some ridicule because the
country did elect donald trump in 2016.
they claimed to be for law and order
they claim to be for the constitution
they're certainly not acting like it and
we're going to have continued coverage
of this
on our instagram page find us at david
pakman show
on instagram one of our sponsors today
is
lucy and they are giving my audience 20
off lucy is a company founded by caltech
scientists with only one mission
which is to help people quit smoking
and vaping by offering a clean
affordable
nicotine alternative now many of you
know you've heard the stories
i've known several people in my life who
have struggled with quitting smoking
i've seen how difficult it can be and
nicotine alternatives can be hugely
helpful
lucy offers a nicotine gum in three
flavors wintergreen
cinnamon and pomegranate they also have
lozenges which come in cherry ice
flavor lucy is affordable it'll ship
right to your door you don't
have to go out to the store shipping is
always free you can buy
single boxes or save with a subscription
it's the year 2020.
it's time to throw the cigarettes away
and get rid of the vape
and lucy can make it easier you'll find
a ton of
excellent reviews online from countless
people
who have used lucy to quit smoking and
vaping
go check them out at lucy.co i've put
the link right underneath this video and
you'll get 20
off when you use the coupon code pacman
and just
a quick disclaimer i'm required to give
these products contain
nicotine nicotine is an addictive
chemical